hello everyone and welcome to a game
where something incredible happened i
don't think i've seen anything like this
um in in all the chess games that i've
seen uh you know for from nhs era it's
really really remarkable especially
since this is a classical game it is
from round eight of this year's norway
chess vishwanathan island versus shakira
mahmud yarov uh the game is quite short
so let's just get to it and then we are
going to discuss what happened this is
uh well it's just weird uh so anand
opened with e4 we have e5 by mamadyarov
knight to f3 knight to f6 going for the
petrov defense and now knight captures
an e5 this is all very very standard d6
going after the knight knight f3 knight
captures an e4 and now
usually d4 and knight the c3 are the
most common moves here anand goes for
the so-called millennium attack with
bishop to d3 and okay mommy daryl of
course knows this he goes back with the
knight knight to f6 castles and the
bishop to e7 also preparing the castle
rook to e1 we have castles by mohammed
araf and now anand brings the bishop
back to f1 uh for for later use and now
there are a couple of games that reach
this position for example uh
buu defeated lekko with with c5 here but
uh here anand plays uh uh um
miderov just plays d5 so he wastes a
move uh but he gets sort of a position
that was never reached before and it is
already as of move eight that we have a
completely new game so okay anand uh
develops the pawn to d4 we have rook to
e8 and now pawn to c4 we have bishop to
g for developing the bishop spinning the
knight
and now knight to c3 we have knights to
c6 and c captures on the 5 we have
knight captures on d5 and pawn to h3 now
challenging uh the bishop here on g4 we
have bishop to h5 and now uh pawn to a3
taking away the b4 square from black's
pieces here mommy there are trades
knight captures pawn captures and bishop
the d6 now getting the bishop to this uh
wonderful diagonal and also offering a
trade of rook so here bishop to e3
ananda declines the trade he wants to
keep the material on the board he does
have the white pieces after all queen to
f6 and now bishop to d3 we have h6 and
here anand
uh goes after the bishop with pawn to g4
we have bishop to g6 and now king the g2
a very important move if bishop captures
you want to be able to capture with the
queen so your knight and f3 will be
defended so king g2 are very nicely
played mommy thereof traits bishop
captures queen captures and denied
knight to e7 uh we have bishop back to
d2 uh of course the knight is coming to
f4 the f4 square is nicely controlled by
all of mahmud's pieces there it will
deliver check and it will be up to on
and
decide what to do from there so here
bishop back to d2 opening up the e file
once again and knight to g6 and this is
the moment where it happened uh anand
played queen to b5 and um interestingly
after playing queen to b5 it was in this
position animal 22 that vishwanathan
anand resigned the game as there is
really nothing more to be done here so
it's remarkable that he had over an hour
on the clock he had an hour and one
minute on the clock it's a classical
game and he resigned here without even
waiting to see uh if mamijaro will see
uh what he saw after playing queen to b5
so there's a i will play you a small
clip
just 24 published it on twitter uh so uh
just uh you know look at his reaction as
soon as he played the move he realized
what he did and uh you know uh pretty
much instantly mamiyarov came to the
board uh and ana resigned the game here
so here you can see it he makes the move
point to b5 uh he hits the clock and now
you can already see that he realized
what he did so it basically took him a
second as soon as he played it he
realized what he did
and um it's an incredible incredible
blunder but uh you know there is nothing
that that can be done about it uh but
yeah like i said what's interesting he
doesn't even wait to see if momodaro
will realize it because um
uh i mean it's what i i believe that's
what everyone would who would do here he
just resigned and mamidarov at first
didn't even realize why why he resigned
mamadirov even said that he actually
thought that queen to b5 was the best
movie in the position but later on he
said that he would uh probably find it
after looking uh
the at the position for for a couple of
moves because um
it's not that difficult to find if you
are you know a
former member of the 2800 club uh but uh
maybe if anand just didn't resign maybe
it would be maybe sort of the
one of those double blindness moments
where mamadourov just doesn't expect
anand to make such a mistake and he
plays something like c6 tries to give up
the b7 pawn or maybe something he plays
something
but yeah uh here anand just showed that
he he's not interested in in sort of
winning the game or maybe just surviving
the game but that he's interested in
playing uh uh precise moves uh doesn't
he he doesn't even care if mamidarov
sees uh the winning idea he he just
resigned here but
you guys
always enjoy finding such moves so feel
free to pause the video here and uh
figure out what anand spotted probably a
second after he made the move while i
give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting the
checkmate and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show the move of
course is queen captures on f3 this is
what anand missed and the point is that
the
queen cannot be captured if king
captures an f3 then knight the h4 is
made in one uh the rook controls the
entire e file bishop controls the g3
square and the knight controls the g2 g2
square and the delivers check on f3 so
that is checkmate bishop of course
covers f4
and there is nothing of course white can
do here so that's uh one thing that
would happen
another thing of course if you don't
capture the queen you can move back king
to g1 but now rook captures sunny one
rook captures uh queen captures on h3 or
down a piece your position is completely
shattered you are losing this uh
no questions asked
uh so yeah after queen to b5 anand
resigned and uh well uh a very very uh
easy victory for mamijarov um
in round eight of uh this year's norway
chess which is uh which is a a terrible
terrible shame for anand uh because uh
he was uh uh doing incredibly well in
this tournament he was really destroying
the classical uh section of the of the
tournament and uh he was a trailing uh
uh
behind magnus
by some half a point and if he
uh
did not lose this in classical he would
be a very very strong contender uh to
actually win the event he even with this
loss i believe he can still win if he
wins the final round in classical uh but
still is just um
you know a brilliant brilliant
tournament uh
tarnished by this queen to b5 move uh
just uh terrible terrible shame uh but
yeah congratulations to everyone uh who
spotted it as mamidyarov said that he
did not know why anand resigned uh when
ananda did resign
uh so that's the game i hope you guys
enjoyed it as it's not not very very
common practice to see this
between top grand masters uh you know uh
to miss a checkmate on move 22 with it
with a queen sacrifice uh just crazy
uh so once again really really hope you
enjoyed this i would like to thank
charles huff nagarjuna
team of salo adrian martin nagorski and
benjamin bogwell for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this
wonderful event until it finishes so
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day